[Musica]
buon pomeriggio tutte oggi detto de vos
portarli dentro un raccordo racconto
utopico su una comunità immaginaria
capace di creare una scuola che forma
gli ideatori vale a dire quelle persone
che nell'età della conoscenza in azione
sono capaci di generare idee che si
trasformano in avventure ventures si
dice in inglese non sono avventure
imprenditoriali va avventure di varia
natura e sono persone nei quali fanno
precedere il ben avere dal ben essere
ben essere con se stessi e con la
comunità nel senso di altruismo di cui
parlava adams messa nella sua famosa
famoso saggio teoria dei sentimenti
morali
gli ideatori sostituiscono i lavoratori
della rivoluzione industriale del vapore
e delle regole di produzione industriale
della elettricità
oggi abbiamo una nuova rivoluzione la
conoscenza in azione che richiede
persone in grado appunto di muovere la
conoscenza verso delle avventure e il
racconto a deve premesse questa è una
prima premessa le persone che hanno
tanta conoscenza esperienza sono i
settori della moda e vedono un cappello
ma i bambini i bambini dicono loro
bisogna essere tutti con voi persone
adulte e perché essere indulgenti perché
le persone adulte che hanno conoscenza
esperienza non hanno l'occhio alla mente
intuitiva l'occhio con la mente
intuitiva i bambini vedono questo vedono
un serpente boa il quale sta
il boiardo ha ingoiato un elefante
seconda premessa siamo nel 1900 e 19
l'intellettuale giovanni papini pubblica
un saggio un pamphlet chiudiamo le
scuole e chiede che le scuole siano
trasformate in laboratori di
sperimentazione dove insegnanti e
studenti insieme possano sollevare
interrogativi prima impensabili e
imparare insieme dagli errori nel 21 il
mata malata gambi sugli archi india un
famoso magazine indiano di allora dice
che la scuola deve far sì che gli
studenti possono pensare con la loro
testa e tutte e due fanno riferimento a
david hume che nel settecento scriveva
l'apprendimento è perdente è chiuso nei
college e nelle cellule degli studenti
non frequenta più il mondo in buona
compagnia e abbiamo un'altra premessa
siamo nel 69 skinner scrive esattamente
quello che leggete se le macchine
cominciano a pensare noi umani
continuiamo a pensare come problema che
oggi si pone drammaticamente essendo noi
di fronte alla intelligenza artificiale
pensare pensare e come 1969 sinners e
per concludere queste premesse negli
anni 90 tiziano terzani famoso
giornalista si reca a tokyo va in una
scuola elementare di tokyo in questa
scuola elementare e la maestra chiede ai
bambini una cosa e per la cosa che
chiede c'e una risposta è una sola non
contro le domande contro le risposte
contro le domande degli insegnanti non
le domande degli studenti
e qual è la cosa che chiede i bambini
cosa accade alla neve quando arriva in
tempo a caldo i bambini rispondono in
coro
la neve si scioglie ma non è così la
verità è un'altra dice un bambino e che
arriva dalla primavera
la risposta estroversa la risposta è
considerata sbagliata
ecco quindi che io penso che da queste
premesse dobbiamo arrivare ad alcune
narrazione conclusive perché non creare
un ponte tra le discipline umanistiche e
di simile scientifiche e addirittura
fonderle perché non creano chiamare
questo monte steam dall'inglese scienza
tecnologia e ingegneria matematica e
arte insieme fuse italiano la parola
suona bene sono come stima essendo
l'ingegneria con la lettera in una
lettera m
e perché non intitolare questo ponte a
madame shuttle è la grande polymath e
poliedrica che frequentava e aveva
familiarità contemporaneamente con
latina con greco le scienze bene e se
facciamo questo che con salcano accade
che vediamo il nuovo panorama e il
panorama dove ci sono corride alla
conoscenza ma vogliamo salito su queste
colline miei piedi saliamo che cosa
vediamo vediamo delle buche di ignoranza
creativa non più le vecchie buche
dell'ignoranza che ci spingeva a entrare
del suo posto disciplinare frequentarlo
fino in fondo e trave dettagli ma
intanto via via che si conoscevano più
dettagli e il mondo era cambiato tono me
non è più vero newton non ha più ragione
non ha più ragione anche einstein e
perfino oggi la vecchiaia guanti st
presenta punti interrogativi
quindi dobbiamo presentare come le vol
per ignoranza creativa diventare
ignoranti non esserlo all'ignoranza
segue la conoscenza non la precede siamo
volpi conosciamo tante cose piccole non
siamo più degli portò spini conoscevano
una cosa ma grande e poi ancora dobbiamo
vedere le scuole del nuove scuole le
radici dell'albero sulle più importante
dei frutti d'albero rovesciato la scuola
di mosche e in america che dice i
bambini debbono poter apprendere secondo
loro abilità la scuola multi linguista
di tokyo che invidia e bambini a
scrivere la stessa frase
diverse lingue perché in questo modo
apprendono cose nuove
e così via tante altre scuole che oggi
stanno nascendo in giro per il mondo
compresi laboratori di sperimentazione
della nostra università
nella mia visita di irlanda per cui io
vi invito tutti voi a diventare
poliedrici polymath e quindi a cambiare
lo stato dell'arte oggi esistente
abbiamo bisogno di pensatori di
cattedrali pensatori che come del
rinascimento hanno cambiato il mondo
vi ringrazio
[Musica]